foreign
to Ukraine now on a day of commemoration
reflection and heartache it's been one
year since Russia launched its
full-scale Invasion upending the lives
of all who live there today ukrainians
wept at memorials for their tens of
thousands dead President Vladimir
zielinski remained defiant vowing to
push for victory in 2023 he called this
day last February the longest day of Our
Lives saying every Ukrainian now has at
least one contact in their phone who
will never pick up the phone again but
he stoically reminded the world Ukraine
did not raise the White Flag instead it
defended the blue and yellow
foreign
begins our coverage tonight and how the
world is marking this Grim anniversary
365 days of Anguish the people of bucha
bear deep wounds it was here that the
world saw some of the first atrocities
committed in the name of Russia's
so-called special military operation an
estimated 400 civilians were killed some
executed in the streets they were
hastily buried only to be exhumed later
to document their cause of death and ID
the bodies Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski said the Terrible Things seen
in this city after the Russians fled
were some of the scariest for him of the
full invasion
Russia and the world expected Kiev to be
seized in days and the government
overthrown yet a year later
may this be proudly proclaimed
everywhere Ukraine is alive
Ukraine
glory to Ukraine glory to the heroes
rang out in Saint Sophia Square soldiers
and families together commemorating what
zelenski coined the year of
invincibility
the conflict is the largest war on
European soil since the second world war
and led to Europe's largest Refugee
crisis the U.N estimates at least 12
million people fled their homes we need
to remind that it's important to win
it's important to send additional weapon
for Leopard 2 tanks are now in the hands
of the Ukrainian military courtesy of
Poland Canadian soldiers have been in
Poland training ukrainians to use the
modern tanks
her son was the last major city
liberated by Ukraine today the streets
mostly empty but here too people speak
of resilience
we survived bombardments didn't we we
survived the atrocities that commitment
to Country and belief that they will be
victorious is something that hasn't
faltered with time no one however
believes that the battles will get any
easier especially as Russia moves to
strengthen its relationships with Iran
and China pharah
crystal commencing in London thank you
Crystal